first can you tell me something about
the style of these movies that James
started in film one that you wanted to
hold especially tight to but then also
something you deliberately strove to do
differently to make the red door feel
like your own Insidious spell yes yes no
problem easy answer
um so one of the things that I wanted to
hold on to was the quirkiness the
there's a there's a there's a uh there's
a the Practical nature of the scares
trying to have everything happen in
camera as much as the system will allow
you and the time will allow you
um uh the and I think this
funny quirky nature that these movies
have the PG-13 nature that can both be
enjoyable for adults but also for a
teenager so that I wanted it to very
much feel like that that being said uh
and also I'll obviously rooted in
a family drama which is really what the
first one was rooted in a family drama
this is just really like family trauma
time now
um and then what I wanted to Branch out
and do on my own I'm um a lot of things
I first and foremost I think the
structure of some of the
the the scares you know some of the
scare sequences that I wanted to be
maybe a little more uh you know in the
in the daytime even though he's got a
great one in the with the dancing boy
and the first one that's in the daytime
with a good Texas switch but but I
wanted something a little more visceral
right so my what I call it the townhouse
sequence of me flipping the things I I I
fought for that over and over even
though I was kind of told you should do
this at night he shouldn't come through
the window all this kind of stuff and I
was like I know but I want to challenge
myself I I I you would expect all of a
sudden to be the guy to be inside we've
already done that so I purposely wanted
to push things and it wasn't always
greeted with sure it was greeted with a
lot of don't know if that'll work but
that's okay it's scarier during the
daytime because you feel safe something
like that shouldn't happen 100 100 then
when you find out who that is then it
makes much more sense so yeah exactly
um I want to touch on the idea of
executing jump scares which are also
very important to this franchise pairing
the right surprise visuals with the
right sound Stingers so having gone
through this experience can you maybe
give me one do and one do not that you
adopted when executing a jump scare well
sure don't lead with uh music don't tell
the audience what to uh music can help
you or the absence of music is equally
important the absence of sound let the
uh lee one out Lee had a great weird
figuring out a scene helping us see and
I even had it cut in there and had a
like a there was some music in there or
something uh and we hadn't finished the
scene but he's like you should try it
without the music he said let the his
quote was let the audience provide the
music the oh and which I thought is
awesome
um so that was very helpful uh it's all
in the setup I mean it's the easy answer
I mean you gotta you gotta look down the
hallway a couple of times before you
look down and hopefully try to give them
sometimes you want to give give them
what they want and sometimes you want to
completely go the other route and turn
on its head you just have to keep the
audience guessing I love that element of
this whole franchise sometimes I just
put an Insidious movie on if I need like
a burst of energy good there's so many
memorable ones
um a broader question here but I was
wondering why specifically Insidious for
your directorial debut is there
something about that franchise versus
another franchise like let's say The
Conjuring that you think speaks to what
you want to do as a director or better
suited how you want it to launch as a
director right well I think like
everything like everything in my I'm
sure like like all of us you you look at
the opportunities you're presented with
the opportunities that are in front of
you your you know your goal shift is
your career shift you know it's it's uh
most of my career is any actor's career
is you're just kind of a gun for hire
right that's just the the nature of the
Beast
um I think with this movie it was a
great fit and incredible opportunity
because nobody makes these movies better
than blumhouse and I've done several
movies with these guys uh and I knew I'd
be taken care of I also knew that the
movie would be seen which lest we forget
is sort of rule number one for me when
making a movie it'd be nice for it to be
seen by people and not just look I made
a movie that was of no interest to me of
just going out for a a passion personal
passion project just to say you did it
so uh all these things just kind of fit
it made sense it made you know Jason
Blum although they may not like to work
with a lot of first-time directors he's
if he does it's a director that's either
come from the some other side of the
business I think of Jordan Peele Joel
Edgerton other guys that have made the
transition with them so there's a huge
bonus in the way that Jason Blum and
Cooper and the guys at Blum House run
their business that enables a director
to go we're gonna let you do your movie
you're going to be protected we're going
to get the team around you and so it was
just it was super comforting and a real
luxury in this climate to be able to
have a summertime movie with a first
time director in a half a billion dollar
franchise so I'm very fortunate I'm
hearing about that that about a company
I admire it's a big part of the reason
why Blum House keeps me coming back for
more non-stop yeah cool congratulations
a directorial debut is a major thing to
celebrate so sincerely congratulations
that's very nice of you thank you